كيف تؤثر اسرائيل في السياسه البريطانيه
نكشف من الداخل كيف تخترق السفاره النظام
البريطاني في الحلقه الاولى المعركه للفوز
بشباب
[موسيقى]
بريطانيا بعد عقود من العنف يبرز تحد جديد
في مواجهه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اسمه بي دي
اس انها الحركه العالميه بمقاطعه اسرائيل
وسحب الاستثمارات منها وفرض العقوبات
عليها والتي تكشفها على حقيقتها كدوله
تمييز عنصري ردت الحكومه الاسرائيليه من
خلال حمله لتحسين صورتها السبب الذي يحتم
علينا محاربه بي دي اس هو كونها خطا ولا
اخلاقيه هي عمليه تديرها وزاره الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه ذات الطابع السري يجندون
بشكل رئيسي ضباط استخبارات سابقين والمهمه
الاساسيه لهم هي مواجهه بيدي اس حول
العالم باستخدام صحفي متخف تكشف وحده
التحقيقات في الجزيره عن نشاطات اسرائيل
السريه في لندن المدينه التي تحولت الى
ساحه حرب نشات حمله بي دي اس بشكل اساسي
في بريطانيا سوف تقابل اناس يتحدون بي دي
اس في كل مستويات السياسه البريطانيه
سفاره اسرائيل اهلا سعيد بلقائك نعمل معا
عن كثب جزء كبير من العمل يجري وراء
الكواليس حزب العمال هو احد اهداف اسرائيل
انها المره الاولى التي يكون فيها رئيس
الحزب نصيرا للحقوق المدنيه الفلسطينيه
سيسعده جدا الا يستمر جريم كوربن في زعامه
حزب العمال انه عمل سري يتسلل الى قلب
النظام الديمقراطي في بريطانيا اعطيك
اسماء اعضاء بالبرلمان لاسقاطه انه تدخل
فضيع في السياسه البريطانيه لا ينبغي ان
يسمح به انها معركه افكار حول كيفيه تصور
اسرائيل والنقاش حولها انها معاديه
للساميه لا ليست معاديه
للساميه
[موسيقى]
نشا مراسلنا المتخفي في المانيا وهو يتغمي
خريج يخطط للاقامه في
بريطانيا يستقر روبن في لندن كناشط طموح
داخل حزب العمال وشديد التعاطف مع
[موسيقى]
اسرائيل بعدما يزيد على شهر من المشاركه
في نشاطات الحزب برز بوضوح كصديق لاسرائيل
وقبل ان يمكث طويلا تعرف على وجه
مالوف انا روبن سفاره اسرائيل سعيد بلقائك
اسمي شاي شاي نعم شاي انه اجتماع لاعضاء
في البرلمان البريطاني ممن يشكلون مجموعه
اصدقاء اسرائيل في حزب عمال ويمارسون
الضغط لصالحها فيما بعد شرح شاي لروبن
المشاكل التي تواجه اصدقاء اسرائيل في حزب
العمال لا يوجد الكثير من الشباب ممن
يرغبون في الانتساب وتلك هي المشكله اذ
تنقطع السلسله وذلك انه لسنوات كان اول ما
يفعله اي عضو في البرلمان هو التوجه
للانضمام في مجموعه اصدقاء اسرائيل في حزب
العمال لم يعودوا يفعلون ذلك في حزب
العمال اما في مجموعه اصدقاء اسرائيل في
حزب المحافظين فيجري ذلك بشكل
تلقائي
[موسيقى]
من بين 40 عضو برلمان جدد فازوا في
الانتخابات الاخيره كل اولئك كانوا ضمن
مجموعه اصدقاء اسرائيل في حزب المحافظين
هذا لم يحدث في مجموعه اصدقاء اسرائيل
العماليه نحن نحتاج لضم مزيد من الناس
وهذا تطلب عملا
كثيرا غرد روبن وكتب مقالات حول اسرائيل
وحزب العمال وبذلك انشا لنفسه هويه على
الانترنت اكتشف وجود عدد كبير من الجماعات
التي تدعم اسرائيل والتي تعرف نفسها بانها
حركات مستقله ذات قواعد
شعبيه ومنها مجموعه اصدقاء اسرائيل في
ساسكس نظم هؤلاء مسيره للاحتجاج على حركه
مؤيده للفلسطينيين تطالب بمقاطعه اسرائيل
كان روبن قد انضم
اليهم فيما بعد وصف شاي الدور الذي تلعبه
السفاره داخل بعض هذه
الحركات
هناك منظمه ذات قاعده شعبيه تسمى اصدقاء
اسرائيل في ساسكس كنت انت قد شاركت في
مظاهرتهم وهناك ائتلاف اسرائيل بريطانيا
وهناك بايكم هناك العديد منها هناك نحن
نؤمن باسرائيل هناك الكثير ساعد شاي في
تاسيس مجموعه شبابيه لاصدقاء اسرائيل في
حزب
المحافظين هناك قسم للشباب داخل جمعيه
اصدقاء اسرائيل في
الحزب نعم اصدقاء اسرائيل في حزب
المحافظين هؤلاء بداوا قبل عام بسبب فكرتي
ثم عندما حاولت فعل الشيء ذاتي في حزب
العمال كانت لديهم في حينه ازمه مع كوربن
كل مجموعه لديها فكره مختلفه بالتحديد
شبيبه اصدقاء اسرائيل في حزب العمال غير
موجوده ذلك هو المكان الوحيد الذي يوجد
فيه فراغ في اللحظه التي يصبح فيها من
الاعضاء 100 او متان حينها تبدا في التحول
الى منظمه حقيقيه لكن ذلك قد يستغرق
سنه
هل سبق ان انشات شيئا كالمجموعة
تربط تحقيقاتنا المسؤوله السياسي في
السفاره بسلسله من المجموعات المؤيده
لاسرائيل اصدقاء اسرائيل في البرلمان
شبيبه المحافظين مجموعات الضغط والحركات
ذات القاعده الشعبيه لشاي علاقات ايضا
بالذراع الشبابي لجمعيه
وهي مركز بحث متنفذ تابع لحزب
العمال اعرف شاي هو صديق
[موسيقى]
حميم عندما تواصلنا مع السفاره
الاسرائيليه اعطونا برنامجا محايدا جدا
قبلت شاي من خلال العمليه وكما تعلم فان
شاي ذاته شخص متزن
جدا اذا تحدثت مع السفاره الاسرائيليه فلن
يمتك بوابل من
الدعايه يبدو ان مهمه الدبلوماسيين
الاسرائيليين هي حشد الدعم لاسرائيل داخل
حزب العمال هناك الكثير من المجموعات التي
تعمل على تثقيف اعضاء البرلمان ولكن لا
يوجد من يقوم بمهمه تثقيف القواعد الشعبيه
داخل الحزب تلك هي الفكره وتحديدا في حزب
العمال اما المحافظون فلا يحتاجون اليها
يقول شاي انه يعرف تقريبا جميع النشطاء في
جمعيه الف
يوجد متان هذا كل ما في الامر كل ذلك في
لندن حوالي 200 ممن هم نشطاء ممن يشاركون
في الحملات ممن ينشطون اعرفهم جميعا
تقريبا اخذت مجموعه من الفابي الى اسرائيل
مارتن كان ضمن تلك المجموعه وكذلك اخرون
يشرح مارتن اي دوبار كيف يساعد دعم
الحكومات الاجنبيه عضويه
الفابي شاي جيد فيما يتعلق بالقوى البشريه
ولديه اتصالات ممتازه في الجانبين في
فلسطين وفي اسرائيل على حد سواء كجزء من
تجربته في العمل وهو شخص رائع ايضا كما
انه يساعد كثيرا ويدعم كثيرا وهو متوازن
جدا شاركت في احدى رحلات جمعيه اصدقاء
اسرائيل في حزب المحافظين الى الشرق
الاوسط توفرت لدينا فرص رائعه للتواصل
وتقابلنا مع فلسطينيين لو ان كل ما قمت به
هو الاعتماد فقط على تلك الرحله ل تشكلت
لديك وجهه نظر احاديه
الجانب مؤخرا رايت شيئا في الفيسبوك مفاده
شيء اهوج في الواقع مفاده ان الاسرائيليين
لا يعطون الفلسطينين ماء او شيئا خلال
رمضان اعلم ان ذلك
باطل بحسب ما اوردته صحيفتها اريتس فان
اسرائيل التي تتحكم بموارد المياه في
الضفه الغربيه المحتله قد قامت فعلا بقطع
المياه زرت اسرائيل ذهبت مع الوفد وبعد ان
رايت كيف تسير الامور هناك اعلم ان ذلك
باطل واعلم ان تلك مجرد دعايه سوف تفهم
ذلك فقط اذا قمت فعلا بزياره ال اكتشف
مراسلنا المتخفي ان شاي لعب دورا في منظمه
اخرى من منظمات حزب العمال وهي الحركه
اليهوديه في الحزب حضر روبن حفل شواء
صيفيا نظمته الحركه كثير من القيل والقال
تحول الى السفاره
الاسرائيليه من تعرف من السفاره
الاسرائيليه شاي انت تعرف شاي انا اعمل مع
شاي تعمل مع شاي انا اعمل تحت امره
السفير في هذه المناسبه اود ايضا ان ارحب
رسميا بايلا في منصبها الجديد
[موسيقى]
كمدير لم تكن ايلا باي حال ذلك الشخص الذي
يتمتع بخبرات فائقه في حزب العمال او في
السياسه ولكن هناك شيء شعرنا في اداره
الحركه اليهوديه في حزب العمال بوصفنا
امناء انه اهم بكثير الا هو انها كانت
واحده منكم لقد اطلعت على هذا الموضوع من
الداخل وخاضت معارك داخل الجامعات جنبا
الى جنب معكم وهو ما شجعنا على اتخاذ قرار
بتعيين ايلا في هذا المنصب لاننا نعتقد
بانها ستستمر وستلعب دورا حيويا جدا في
رياده النضال ضد معادات الساميه داخل حزب
[تصفيق]
العمال مرحبا يا جماعه لقد جرى التعريف
بان ايلا مسؤوله الشواء والمديره الجديده
لحركه اليهوديه في حزب
العمال هيا بنا نخرج ونغير حزب العمال نحو
الافضل ونؤثر في رسم مستقبل هذا البلد من
خلال مجتمع تقدمي قوي
[تصفيق]
وعادل
[موسيقى]
ما حصل بعد ذلك ادهش مراسلنا
المتخفي طلب شاي من روبن ان يصبح جزءا من
خطه السفاره الاسرائيليه لجذب الشباب من
اعضاء حزب العمال اصدقاء اسرائيل في
العمال يسعون الى يريدون تاسيس فرع لشبيب
اصدقاء اسرائيل في حزب العمال الفكره هي
اقامه شيء يشبه الفرع حتى يعمل مع الشباب
ولذلك ما اود قوله هو انك اذا كان لديك
وقت فراغ واذا ما كنت ترغب في المشاركه
اظن ان ما يبحثون عنه هو شخص تناط به مهمه
تدشينه وادارته نحتاج لان نفكر بشان ما
الذي بامكانك ان
تفعله ثم اقترح الشاي انه بالاضافه الى
اقامه شبيبه اصدقاء اسرائيل في حزب العمال
على روبن ان يتقدم بطلب عمل لدى السفاره
الاسرائيليه ودعي الى اجتماع خاص في احد ف
نا دق لندن حضر اللقاء موظفون في السفاره
وبريطانيون مناصرون لاسرائيل ثم ينفرد احد
الدبلوماسيين الاسرائيليين بروبن وياخذه
جانبا احتاج الى شخص يعمل في السفاره لا
ادري ان كان ذلك مهما
لك شاي حدثني عن ذلك وسلمته نسخه من سيره
الذاتيه هذا هو نعم هذا هو ونبحث كذلك عن
شخص يعمل على قضيه دي اس باسرها لاجراء
ابحاث حولها من يكونون قليلا من
الاستراتيجي بشان هذا الموضوع لا ادري ان
كان اي من هذين الامرين قد يروق لك شعرت
اي روس المديره الجديده للحركه اليهوديه
في حزب العمال بالسعاده لدى سماعها بخطه
روبن كنت اعمل في السفاره هنا واستطيع
مساعدتك واحب ان احضر اي نشاط تنظمون
اعتبرني المعجبه رقم
واحد كان ضيف الشرف وزيرا في الحكومه
الاسرا
نشات على عقيده ان ارض اسرائيل باسرها هي
ملك للشعب اليهودي لا مجال للتنازل عن
ذلك لا اخلاقيا ولا
دينيا ارض اسرائيل هي ملك للشعب
اليهودي استحدثت وزاره الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه في اسرائيل لمواجهه حركه بي
دي اس انها تشكل تهديدا استراتيجيا
لمستقبل اسرائيل لاننا اذا ما سمحنا لهم
بالاستمرار في نشر كل ذلك الكذب الذي
يفترون على اسرائيل فاننا سنخسر ذلك الجيل
الرائع من الشباب ولربما خرج من هنا قاده
المستقبل في بريطانيا او في غيرها من
البلدان وحينها سيظنون ان اسرائيل بلد سيء
جدا اثناء اجتماع اخر ذهب شاي وجه روبن
حول كيفيه انشاء مجموعه مؤيده لاسرائيل
اساسا الناس الذين ينتسبون الى حزب العمال
هم من الشباب كيف تتواصل وتتحدث معهم
اعتقد بادئ ذي بدء انك بحاجه لبيع شيء ما
صحيح نظريا قد يوافق اصدقاء اسرائيل في
حزب العمال على تنظيم وفد لزياره اسرائيل
تلك دائما بدايه جيده ثانيا ربما تحتاج
الى متحدث مثير للاهتمام وهذا امر يمكن
للسفاره ان تساعد فيه كما يمكن لاصدقاء
اسرائيل في العمال ان يساعدوا فيه اذا كنت
تتطوع كي تكون رئيسا للمنظمه فانت بحاجه
نظريه لشخص يقوم بمتابعه وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي والى شخص تناط به مهمه العنايه
بامر المتحدثين او النشاطات او شخص تناط
به مهمه تراس الوفد المتوجه الى اسرائيل
ثم بعد ذلك بعد ذلك يشكل الناس الهيكل
الجديد ومن ثم لا تعود تلك مسؤوليتك وحدك
ثم يصبح لديك سته اشخاص بمسؤوليات نوعا ما
وهم يشكلون اللجنه المشرفه على المنظمه
هذا هو تلك هي الطريقه التي تقيم بها
منظمه بمن يجب ان اتصل مايكل مايكل
روبين مايكل
روبن مايكل
روب اخبر مايكل ان لديك فكره وانك ترغب في
المضي قدوما بها ما هو موقعه في اصدقاء
اسرائيل في حزب العمال هو منسق
بدات حديثا العمل في اصدقاء اسرائيل في
حزب العمال كنت قبل ذلك رئيس الطلاب في
الحزب تعرفت على شاي من خلال نشاطي
وانجزنا بعض الامور معا لنقف هنا في
الشمس تحدثنا عن تنظيم حفل استقبال
بمشروبات واستئجار قاعه فوق حانه مثل هذه
نصرف قليلا من المال داخل الحانه لجذب
الناس بامكانك دعوه بعض البرلمانيين
المؤيدين اشخاص مثل جوان ريال بامكانها ان
تاتي وتتحدث وتتاح للناس بذلك فرصه للقاء
[موسيقى]
بها وهي ايضا على تواصل مع
شاي نعم نعم نعمل كثيرا مع السفير ومع
السفاره ولذلك فهي تتحدث مع شاي في معظم
الايام يبدو ان اصدقاء اسرائيل في حزب
العمال ينظرون الى الابعد اقل ما يقال هو
ان حزب العمال في هذه اللحظه ليس في وضع
جيد هناك الكثير من الشباب الذين ينضمون
ممن هم معتدلون وممن لديهم اراء جيده حول
اسرائيل اظن اننا لا نولي هؤلاء كثيرا من
الاهتمام هم الذين سيكونون في البرلمان
بعد عش الى 15 سنه اخبره روبن عن اهتمام
السفاره الاسرائيليه
بتجنيده اعلم بوجود وظائف شاغره ولذا عليك
ان تتحدث مع شاي
ضرب مثلا كيف لوظيفه في السفاره ان تساهم
في تقدم المراه داخل المنظومه
السياسيه كانت الى اروز قبل عامين اثنين
رئيسه ليو جي اس اتحاد الطلبه اليهود انها
تعمل في السفاره ولكنها تترك السفاره
لتنضم الى الحركه اليهوديه في حزب
العمال حلت اداره جديده وقررت توظيف شخص
يساعد في بعض الامور ثم اثير مووضوع
الساميه وحسنت الحركه اليهوديه في حزب
العمال بشكل كبير من وضعها قالوا انه ربما
يتوجب علينا ان نوظف شخصا سياسيا يدري ما
الذي يفعله قبل ذلك كنت في السفاره اعمل
مع شاي في نفس الوقت تقريبا الذي عادت فيه
الحركه اليهوديه في حزب العمال للظهور
بقياده جيريمي نيو مارك والذي وظف فيما
بعد ال روز مديره للحركه كانت القصه
الكبيره تدور حول طالب شاب في اوكسفورد
زعم بان حزب العمال ومعظم الطلاب ين في
اوكسفورد كانوا معادين للساميه لم يقدم اي
ادله على الاطلاق سوى انهم روجوا لاسبوع
الابارتايد الاسرائيلي وهو حدث معروف جيدا
وينظم داخل الجامعات حول العالم كان رئيس
طلاب حزب العمال في ذلك الوقت مايكل
روبن كانت هناك مزاعم بمعدات الساميه في
نادي حزب العمال اجريت التحقيق في ذلك اذ
كنت رئيس الطلاب كان تقريرا صادرا عن طلاب
حزب العمال كانت نوعا ما الحاله الاولى
لمعا
كانت هناك الكثير من التسريبات الاعلاميه
والكثير من الكلام حول كيف يتم التستر على
معاداه
الساميه نشرت الصحف البريطانيه تقارير حول
معاداه الساميه داخل حزب العمال كان احد
المستهدفين ماليا بعطيه التي انتخبت حديثا
زعيمه للاتحاد الوطني لطلبه بريطانيا لقد
وصفت بيرمنغهام بانها موقع متقدم
للصهيونيه لان فيها مجتمعا يهوديا كبيرا
كان ذلك امرا في غايه السوء ففي تقاليد
الاتحاد الوطني للطلبه وتقاليد السياسه في
بريطانيا كان الخطاب المعادي لاسرائيل
شديدا جدا وكانما الصهيونيه شيء قبيح
وكانك حينما تسمي نفسك صهيونيا فانت بذلك
تعرض نفسك للتمزق يقولون انهم ضد العنصريه
ويقولون انهم لا يميزون بين الناس ولكن
حين يبلغ الامر بمعاداته ويه هذا الحد
فانا ارى انها تتحول الى معاداه
للساميه مع عام
الاستيطان الاسرائيلي ينتشر الدعم لحركه
بيدي اس داخل الجامعات حول العالم وفي
بريطانيا هي التي حسمت نتيجه انتخابات
2016 لرئاسه الاتحاد الوطني
للطلبه اسرائيل حيث توجد الان هل يمثل ذلك
اشكالا بالنسبه
لك اسرائيل من حيث سلوكها تمثل اشكالا
بالنسبه لي هل تعتبرين نفسك معاديه
للصهيونيه نعم هذا صحيح بعطيه انها غايه
في السوء هل تعرف روبي يانج هل سمعت بروبي
يانج ماليه هي رئيس الاتحاد الوطني للطلبه
وروبي هو واحد من النواب الخمسه للرئيس
انه طالب عمالي وهو في الواقع جيد فيما
يتعلق باسرائيل ذهب في رحله اليها ولذلك
فقد راى اسرائيل انهم من انصار اسرائيل
ولذلك يوجد داخل الاتحاد الوطني للطلاب من
هم متوازن وجيد نائب رئيس اخر ريتشارد
بروكس اتخذ اجراء غير اعتيادي حين زعم ان
انتقاد ابوعطيه لاسرائيل يرقى الى معاداه
الساميه لا يمكنني ان اقبل بزعيم منتخب
اذا كان عنصريا الهياكل الداخليه للاتحاد
الوطني للطلاب لا تسمح في العاده لنائب
الرئيس ان يبادر وينتقد الرئيس علانيا عبر
الاذاعه الوطنيه ولكن عليك القيام بما هو
واجب تقول ماليا ان انتقاداتها ذات طبيعه
سياسيه هي تتحدث عن الصهيونيه وليس عن
الناس الذين ينتسبون الى
اليهوديه الطلاب اليهود هم الذين من حقهم
تعريف معادات الساميه حيث ان 50 من رؤساء
اتحاد الطلبه اليهود بينوا اثناء الاعداد
الانعقاد المؤتمر الوطني ان لديهم ما
يقلقهم بسبب بعض
الخطابات لم يذكر بروكس انه قبل تلك
المقابله باسابيع توجه الى اسرائيل ضمن
وفد اتحاد الطلبه اليهود لقد تلقيت تثقيفا
حول كل هذه الامور كما تحدثت مع اشخاص في
اتحاد الطلبه اليهود واخذت في رحله الى
اسرائيل كان ذلك قبل شهرين ولذلك فقد
تعلمت الكثير ومنذ ذلك الحين وانا اشعر
بثقه كافيه لابدا بالحديث عن بعض القضايا
بشكل اكثر
جديه من الواضح ان ماليه سيئه كنت حاضرا
في المؤتمر عندما انتخبت كنا نروج للشخص
الذي نزل منافسا لها لاننا لم نكن نرغب في
ان تنجح من الواضحه اننا لم
نفرح اثناء الحمله الانتخابيه عقد ريتشارد
بروكس لقاءات خاصه مع راسل لانجر مدير
الحملات في اتحاد الطلبه اليهود وكان
حاضرا في الاجتماع ايضا مايكل
روبن كان مايكل رئيس الطلبه العماليين في
العام الماضي عملت معه ومع راسل من اتحاد
الطلبه اليهود كنا نجتمع ونخطط ونناقش
قضايانا السريه لتمكين الناس المعتدلين من
ان ينتخبوا ليحتلوا مواقع معينه بعد ان تم
تقديمه من قبل السفاره الاسرائيليه كمتطوع
في اصدقاء اسرائيل تدرس مراسلنا المتخف في
امكانيه الاطاحه برئيسه الاتحاد بمساعده
ريتشارد
بروكس كيف يمكننا الاتصال بالاشخاص الذين
يسعون
لمعارضتها بامكانك ان تتكلم معي فانا الذي
انظم نعم فقط ابعث لي برساله مختصره حينما
ترغب في المحادثه مع شخص داخل منطقه
جغرافيه
ما كما كشفت تحقيقاتنا عن ان اتحاد الطلب
اليهود الذي رتب لناقد ماليا بعطيه
ومعارضيها رحلات الى اسرائيل تلقى اموالا
من السفاره
الاسرائيليه تمنح السفاره الاسرائيليه في
بريطانيا اموالا لتحد الطلبه اليهود بمجرد
ما تشارك في نشاطات اتحاد طلبه اليهود
فانهم يوصلونك عملت اختي في السفاره لوقت
قصير وكانت تلك اول وظيفه لها انها منبر
جيد للعمل لمده
عام في عام
2016 ترشح شابيرا لانتخابات اتحاد الطلبه
اليهود ولكنه لم يفلح كما تلقى تمويلا من
اسرائيل لانشاء مركز بحث داخل الجامعه فاس
مركز بنسكر بالتعاون مع الطالب السابق في
جامعه لندن اليوت
ميلر في وزاره الخارجيه في دائره شؤون
الكونجرس اقوم بكل ما له علاقه بالكونجرس
او
بمنظمه
هناك شخص من ورائي انه في اسرائيل
وبامكانه ان يحصل على مبلغ ربع مليون جنيه
استرليني من التبرعات انه شخص
عبقري كما اكدوا وللمره الاولى ان ايباك
الامريكيه التي تمارس الضغط لصالح اسرائيل
تحول الاموال الى داخل حرم الجامعات
البريطانيه عبر
بنسكر مجموعات مثل ااك منحت بعض المال
توجهنا الى ايباك في شهر مارس وعملنا مع
ويبقى ال ميلر صاحب صوت هادر في مرجل
السياسات الطلابيه في لندن انتم لا
تحترمون النساء انتم لا تحترمون
المثليين انا واليوت انشانا معا مركز
بنسكر وهدفنا هو اعاده تاطير الخطاب داخل
حرم الجامعات في بريطانيا اشعر بان ثمه
الكثير جدا مما نحتاج الى فعله في الحقل
التعليمي جلب مختلف المتحدثين من كل ارجاء
الطيف السياسي وتقديم خطاب
اخر انه دين عنيف دين
[موسيقى]
عنيف في الحلقه الثانيه المزيد من الادله
على تورط اسرائيل في حزب العمال البريطاني
نعمل معا عن كثب جزء كبير من العمل يجري
وراء الكواليس وحول الاموال التي تمنحها
اسرائيل لاعضاء البرلمان لتحسين صورتها
يزيد عن المليون مال
كثير